one of the victims killed on 9 11 was a
local teacher barbara edwards
today students at palo verde high school
held a remembrance ceremony in her honor
our hector mejia spoke with her family
and has the tribute
20 years ago tomorrow tragedy struck our
school and our nation
on september 11th palo verde high school
teacher barbara edwards was on the plane
that crashed into the pentagon an annual
ceremony honors her legacy on campus
my mother was just a fun loving joyous
person she always saw the good in people
scott edwards is the youngest of three
sons she left behind she would be blown
away and grateful but i think she would
say oh you guys don't have to do this
for me because she was just a very
humble person edwards taught french and
german here she loved the school she
loved
the kids and the students scott was 25
years old when his mother was killed in
the attack my son was about he was just
about three years old
so he got to spend a few years with her
mostly we missed her her laughter and
her joy
so the the stories that people come up
and tell me like hey my favorite story
is when your mom you know showed up to a
meeting dressed as a french fry hector
mejia reporting 8 news now